no touch mom its touch my okay that's
rude
let's move over to minute well two
minutes to my legs okay I warned you oh
wow okay this is this an online blog aim
what are we doing here you played real
openings right it's a one night game I'm
gonna castlelong
so I get scared
uh-uh-uh I know what you're doing to me
don't intimidate me I just got here I'm
sure he's not going to attack you on the
queenside
Oh Brooke Wow tactics are coming I don't
have a fear that's my problem
I have Magnus people love drama at least
make it close my apologies
he once win that badly
there's knees down to 36 seconds playing
at the home of Julian Jerry Miller I
posted them this evening okay we going
here we go again game I played way too
fast
I tried to see if I can forest faster I
might even push the draw to a loss
position he didn't he didn't see a rook
pawn too thick